el 25 de diciembre de 2021 en kurú en la
guayana francesa son muchas muchas horas
de trabajo muchos años de trabajo y
todos los seguidos nos trajeron a este
preciso momento
el cohete ariane-5 lanzó al espacio el
telescopio más potente jamás construido
y luego tenemos que esperar unos minutos
más hasta el desacoplamiento son como
minutos de apnea cada paso era muy
importante que el sucesor del telescopio
hubble el james webb que lleva el nombre
de un antiguo director de la nasa es una
joya de la tecnología es el fruto de 30
años de investigación y de una misión de
10 mil millones de dólares
es como una crisálida que al final
despliega sus alas y se convierte en una
hermosa mariposa
el james webb fue construido más de diez
años después del hubble así que hay
nuevas tecnologías además es mucho más
grande lo podrá captar mucho más luz
desde mucho más lejos en el espacio
[Música]
la ventaja del espacio para la
astronomía el espacio es extraordinario
porque desde la tierra tenemos
telescopios que funcionan muy bien pero
la atmósfera siempre es turbulenta
siempre hay viento siempre hay efectos
térmicos por lo que las imágenes en
lugar de ser perfectamente precisas se
distorsionan se difuminan en foco
y
en los años 80 pierde el trabajo en el
diseño de telescopios en uno de los
centros de la nasa
cuando el joven fue puesto en órbita a
600 kilómetros en la tierra su director
le pidió que empezara a trabajar desde
ya en un telescopio de nueva generación
que fuera mucho más eficaz
[Música]
aunque pierre pensó inicialmente en un
telescopio óptico capaz de captar la luz
visible
sus investigaciones pronto le hicieron
cambiar de opinión
[Música]
lo que pasó fue que hubo una conferencia
que fue fundamental en esa conferencia
en 1989 nos dimos cuenta de que no
queríamos hacer un telescopio más grande
que funcionará en el ámbito óptico
queríamos un telescopio que funcionara
en el infrarrojo
antes de su imagen dongfang el
infrarrojo es una onda invisible a
simple vista pero que puede ser
percibida por instrumentos sensibles al
calor
hay muchas razones por las que los
astrónomos y científicos quieren
observar el universo en el infrarrojo
una de ellas es el hecho de que en el
espacio la luz que se propaga se estira
con el mismo universo con lo que se
llama la expansión de nuestro universo
lo que hace que la luz que podía ser
visible en un momento dado al ser
estirada se vuelve invisible a nuestros
ojos con la ayuda del infrarrojo el
telescopio james webb permitirá ver esas
primeras luces que emitieron las
primeras estrellas y por tanto
retroceder en la historia del universo
mucho más allá de lo que hemos podido
retroceder hasta ahora
durante 30 años la nasa trabajó en la
construcción de un telescopio sensible
al infrarrojo
el problema es que la tierra y el sol
emiten calor que podría interferir con
esas captaciones
para evitarlo bajo el espejo del
telescopio se colocó un escudo de cinco
capas de grosor tan grande como una
cancha de tenis
la comunicación con la tierra se hace
con todos los instrumentos que están en
busca tel y tal en esta parte de acá del
lado de la tierra y la observación de
las estrellas se hace desde el otro lado
que está protegido del sol por este
escudo térmico
para lograr tal hazaña la nasa colaboro
con la agencia espacial canadiense y la
agencia espacial europea
esta última proporción o dos de los
cuatro instrumentos el james webb
así como el lanzador el cohete ariane-5
[Música]
para el lanzamiento de este telescopio
necesitábamos dos criterios principales
uno era el desempeño es decir la
posibilidad de enviar la masa de este
telescopio que era de algo más de seis
toneladas al punto de transferencia al
que debía ir y luego un volumen muy
grande es un telescopio que ocupa mucho
espacio
entonces se necesitaba mucho espacio
dentro de la copia por lo que había muy
pocos lanzadores en el mundo que
pudieran cumplir con esos criterios
tras su despliegue en el espacio el
james webb continuó su camino hacia la
órbita
actualmente se encuentra en el punto de
lagrange 2 a 15 millones de kilómetros
en la tierra de espalda al sol y de cara
al universo profundo
[Música]
y el estudio de las atmósferas de
planetas lejanos puede dar pistas sobre
la existencia de actividad biológica
quizás de vida en estos planetas lejanos
no tenemos instrumentos que tengan la
sensibilidad para permitirnos ver eso
hoy el james webb abrirá una puerta a la
detección de vida extraterrestre
una puerta hacia el futuro y una mejor
comprensión de los orígenes del universo
es la misión de este revolucionario
telescopio
[Música]